طبعا لو نقارنها مثلا من خمسه او سبع سنين
على الاقل نقول الحين صار في شفافيه يعني
صار في تواصل صار فيه يعني صح ان الانباط
الان نسمع عنها كثير لكن قبل في كثير ناس
ما كانت تعرف عن الامراض فاهم شيء اللي
صار عندنا الحين التوعيه وهذا اهم شيء ان
الناس تعرف انه في اثار عدم من الناس تروح
لاي موقع في عندك وحده والله انا اهوى
الاثار ابغى اجمع هذا لا
فصار عندك هنا في حفريات لكن العدد ما زال
قليل مقارنه بحجم المملكه بحجم الحضارات
اللي موجوده عندنا
يعني اذا يعني ما هي دعوته في هذا الخصوص
بحكم تخصصك فيها
المعاناتك الميدانيه يعني انا الى الان ما
اشتغلت ميدانيا طبعا
التعاون مع بعثات يعني الكل عصر يعني مثلا
انا قاعده ابغى افهم مثلا لغز هجره
الانسان من افريقيا للجزيره العربيه
في المواقع يعني نروح المواقع على هذا
الانسان المتحضر الاول القديم لان هذه
كلها تفكلك لغز عشان هي زي قاعده تجمع انت
عشان تفهم فنعرف هذه المواقع هل فيها ياكل
عظميه لهذه الفترات هل في حضاره مختصه
موجوده فقط عندنا بالمملكه
وكمان
ممكن نقول نشر الابحاث اكثر لانه في كثير
الابحاث العلميه اللي صارت في المملكه
سهول اني انا اقدر اوصل لها يعني تكون
بشكل عام وهذا تعتقدين انه مش بالشكل
المطلوب اليوم يعني هو موجود لكن مو
بالشكل المطلوب بالشكل المطلوب ايضا
سعاد ايضا سريع كيف تقيمين تعامل الناس
العاديين الواحد يلقى له شيء ولا يلقى له
هل ارتفع مستوى الثقافه
صراحه نشوف مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في
كثير ناس يعني تروح مثلا
من موقع فتلقاها راجعه للبيت وتصور
الادوات يعني انت كده هدمت 50% من الماده
العلميه اللي هي انت وين لقيتها كيف شكلها
ايش كان جنبها فهنا في ناس وفي ناس يحطون
عليها
مثلا عليه صدى يروح مثلا يسمع يقرا انه في
زيت زيتون لا في ناس متخصصه هي اللي تعمل
وهي اللي تقوم بترميم القطع يعني زي مره
مثلا كان في فريق ايطالي قصير عمره
بالاردن جاي بس عشان يشيل طبقه الرماد من
الرسومات لان فقط تخيل فريق يعني هذا تخصص
الحاله فالتايد ما راح يشيل من من الحجم
انه يشيل الاشياء العنيفه بس المشكله انه
كذا انت قاعد تتلاعب بالتاريخ يعني ممكن
انت القرش اللي اخذته هو القرش الوحيد
اللي موجود في كل المنطقه يذلني ان في
حضاره هذه مرت من المنطقه فعدم الاستهتار
ان اي احد يروح ياخذها وهذه ملك للدوله ما
حد يملكها انا بس ال سؤال ختامي بس
اذكر في بعض الدول الاخرى عربيه وغير
عربيه في جهه خاصه هي اللي تتولى حمايه
الاثار
مش هيئه علميه او لا لا جهه يعني زي بعضهم
يسميها شرطه الاثار او ما ادري هل هل
موجود هذا عندنا ولا حسب علمي ما صراحه ما
اعرف اذا موجود او لا عندي لانه تعرف هذا
المجال كله لسه عندنا جديد قاعد يعني ينشف
المهم يعني طبعا لانه زي ما قلت لك الحين
يعني في ناس تروح الى اليوم وتروح تاخذ اي
قطعه وتروح لبيتها وتصورها
بالضبط والتجاره انت كذا قاعد تلعب
بالتاريخ يعني
فعندك مثلا الناس اللي تروح ممكن حتى من
الكوارث الطبيعيه زي السيور الامطار حوامل
عوامل الحث والتاني هذي كلها تلعب دور
فمثلا اذا موقع راح مثلا قلت احد من
جدرانه ينهد سرعه معالجه معالجه الموقع
على الاقل اعمال بسيطه عشان نحافظ عليه
المواقع اللي تكون عندك مثلا حتى على
النقوش القديمه تلقى ناس لسه قاعده تشخمط
فوقها فهذه كلها تحتاج حمايه مراق به ممكن
استعانه بالتكنولوجيا كاميرات حساسات او
غيرها يعني التجربه على فكره عملت في
موضوع البيئه البيئه وحمايه واثمرت ثمار
جيده يعني حمايه الاشباح
سبب وجود قوانين